police in New Orleans are trying to
determine the motive in a mass shooting
near the city's famed French Quarter ten
people were wounded two critically after
a gunman opened fire early yesterday
near the tourist area our national
correspondent Jericka Duncan is here
jurika des police have a suspect
not exactly here's what we know right
now one person was detained near the
scene but no arrests have been made
police are calling it a cowardly and
senseless act that cannot and will not
be tolerated the shots erupted Adan the
edge of New Orleans is busy French
Quarter just before 3:30 Sunday morning
police officers were standing nearby
already patrolling the area because of
the Bayou Classic a popular annual
college football game that ended hours
earlier at first authorities say some
officers thought they were being fired
at but couldn't tell where the shots
were coming from they later discovered
ten victims including one person shot in
the chest another in the torso the New
Orleans Police Superintendent says
violent crime is actually down in the
city for a fourth straight year he vows
he will not allow the acts of a few to
deter New Orleans from continuing that
trend we also reached out to the FBI
this morning they say that they are
coordinating with local police but many
people go to the French Quarter we've
all been there I think it's a good time
let the good times roll and to no fault
of your own you're caught up and and it
was so crowded that's why I'm gonna at
least were so confused about where the
shots were gonna be make an arrest soon
thank you jerrika